le mar je suis né et j'ai été élevé à
neuilly et depuis toujours je suis
passionnée de mode les de la maison
chanel plus particulièrement quand
j'étais petit je regardais tous leurs
défilés je collectionnais toutes leurs
pubs et je les afficher dans la chambre
les murs étaient tapissés de claudia
schiffer de vesta galon et de sacs
matelassés d'ailleurs je rêvais de la
voir le fameux sac matelassé chanel
du coup devenu adulte je me suis dit que
le plus simple
c'était quand même de diriger la maison
chanel donc comme études j'ai fait
management des entreprises de mode
logique après j'ai commencé à travailler
dans des bureaux de tendances dans des
maisons de couture logique et
aujourd'hui je suis travailleur social
dans un centre pour sans abri
oui la vie est étonnante
tout commence il ya sept ans à l'époque
je viens de fermer ma boîte
j'ai un peu de temps libre devant moi
j'ai envie de les consacrer à des gens
dans le besoin
bon moi les gens dans le besoin j'en ai
une image assez vague parce qu'à neuilly
y en a pas énormément mais j'ai envie
d'agir
donc j'arrive dans ce centre pour sans
abri qu'on appelle un accueil de jour
ma naïveté en bandoulière ils me
prennent comme bénévole à tout faire je
l'aurais bien exposé que j'avais une
vraie expertise mode ou pas énormément
bondues et les premières semaines
j'observe je vois que le centre
accueille des hommes et des femmes
majeures et isolé c'est à dire sans
enfants qui vivent pour la plupart à la
rue qui viennent là se reposer boire un
café prendre une douche laver leurs
vêtements voir un médecin juriste un
travailleur social faire une demande
d'hébergement
bref je vois défiler toute la misère du
monde des gens fatigués là s'est perdu
en colère alcoolique psychotique et face
à eux
je vois des salariés assez fascinant des
gens capables dans la même matinée avec
la même bienveillance de répondre à ce
monsieur déjà bien alcoolisé qui vous
souffle son haleine de mauvais vin dans
le nez alors que vous avez pas eu le
temps de voir votre premier café à cette
dame ampleur qui s'est fait voler ses
affaires dans la rue la nuit dernière à
ce monsieur exaspéré qui vous traite de
bon à rien payé à rien
cet autre qui a traversé la méditerranée
parce qu'on le dit qu'en france il
trouverait facilement du boulot ou à
cette dame qui entend des voix qui part
des sondés paul face à toutes ces
situations je vois les travailleurs
sociaux comme les contorsionnistes
aj l'infatigable passer de l'une à
l'autre avec une patience et une
bienveillance constante sourire rassurer
console est conseillé écouter encore et
encore
x 250 personnes par jour et je me dis
eux quand ils se lèvent le matin c'est
pour faire le bien moi de mon côté j'ai
l'impression que je commence à force de
les côtoyer travaillé au centre à
acquérir un peu de ses qualités humaines
de tolérance d'écouté qui dans mon cas
et pas forcément superflu et qu'en plus
ces qualités là peuvent permettre
concrètement d'aider des gens au même
moment il faut que je m'en remettre à
chercher du boulot je peux décemment pas
rester bénévoles toute ma vie donc j'en
vois des cv je passe des entretiens je
me retrouve face à des managers qui me
posent des questions de genre est ce que
vous vous considérez
[Musique]
un cerveau quoi prendre 10 aces composez
vous êtes plutôt intelligente plutôt
débile ou encore comment feriez vous
chutez prix de crayon bon moi j'ai
rapidement jeudi sera peut être possible
hein je suis en train de découvrir comme
ah bon tu es né sang peut sauver le
monde je vais pas tout lâcher pour faire
chuter le prix d'un crayon donc je suis
resté au centre j'ai appris le métier et
je suis devenu travailleur social et à
mesure que je maîtrisais de plus en plus
ce métier je me suis aperçu d'une chose
c'est que les gens viennent chez nous
avec des demandes de base d'hébergement
d'accès aux soins au travail
mais parfois les réponses peuvent être
longue à venir et le temps d'attentes
peut être très difficile pour eux vous
connaissez peut-être cette situation si
vous avez été au chômage par exemple
vous faites tout ce que vous pouvez pour
chercher un travail puis un nombre donné
vous maîtrisez plus entièrement la
situation la seule chose que vous avez à
faire c'est prendre votre mal en
patience
et dans ces cas là qu'est ce qu'on fait
bon se tourner vers sa famille vers ses
amis vers ce qu'on appelle les liens
sociaux qui nous caractérise nous les
humains serge paugam qui est un
sociologue spécialiste de la question
le décrit en disant l'homo sociologique
us est liée aux autres et à la société
non seulement pour assurer sa protection
face aux aléas de la vie mais aussi pour
satisfaire son besoin vital de
reconnaissance source de son identité de
son existence en tant qu'homme son
besoin vital de reconnaissance c'est à
dire que nous les humains on n'a pas
juste besoin de vivre on a besoin
d'exister et pour exister on a besoin
d'être reconnu par les autres et par la
société c'est ce qui est très bien
illustré dans la pyramide de maslow vous
connaissez sûrement natio c'était un
psychologue américain au xxème siècle
qui était spécialisée sur la notion de
motivation chez l'homme il a établi qu
on avait des besoins graduelle qu'on
satisfaisait
à mesure la base de nos besoins sont des
besoins physiologiques respirer boire
manger et dormir quand ils sont
satisfaits en grimper au top de la
pyramide sont des besoins psychologiques
qui ont trait au regard qu'on porte sur
soi même que les autres nous renvoie et
à ce qu'on réalise qui nous rend heureux
et fier dans la vie est bien plus on est
en difficulté sociale
plus on dégringole la pyramide et
souvent les gens quand ils arrivent chez
nous au centre leurs besoins de base
sont même plus totalement satisfait donc
notre rôle pour ceux qui le peuvent pour
ceux qui le veulent c'est de les aider à
regrimper les marches de cette pyramide
c'est de les aider à aller chercher au
fond de l'énergie qui redonne envie
d'exister
c'est valable pour tous les humains et
c'est particulièrement important pour
les femmes les femmes à la rue elles ont
l'habitude de se cacher pour se protéger
des prédateurs elles font tout ce
qu'elles peuvent pour se rendre
invisible or se rendre invisible pour
essayer d'exister c'est quand même
compliqué ces dix dernières années le
nombre de femmes en grande précarité a
fortement augmenté
aujourd'hui elle représente 38% des sdf
or jusqu'à il ya deux ans dans paris sur
la douzaine d'accueil qui existe est
mixte et qui accueillait majoritairement
des hommes y en avait un seul qui était
dédiée spécifiquement aux femmes alors
dans le centre où je travaille
on a décidé de créer un espace
spécifiquement dédié à l'accueil des
femmes et qu'ils soient centrées sur la
notion d' estime dessous ce lieu propose
différentes activités du yoga à
l'écriture du bien-être à la lecture aux
groupes de parole et accueillent tous
types de femmes des femmes jeunes
d'autres moins des femmes qui ont subi
des violences d'autres des parcours
migratoire compliqué des femmes qui
travaillent
bref des femmes qui au delà de leur
situation actuelle
au temps passé et en à venir voir des
envies et projets des rêves auxquels on
peut accorder un peu d'attention parce
que le plus compliqué pour une femme en
précarité c'est qu'on sous-estimé ses
envies ou pire qu'on la regarde avec
pitié
le fait d'être dans l'oeil et que les
gens nous renvoie une image qui ne
correspond pas ça m'a touché et fait
beaucoup de faits j'ai pas choisi d'être
à paris
bien au contraire je suis ambitieuse et
j'avais un réussite est défini l'obésité
et vous viendra vol mais à la vie un
discours plus mais on ne peut pas
accepter beaucoup de mains de réduire
cette idée stif
mais ça m'a ouvert les yeux et donné
beaucoup de courage pour l'avancé et
prouver aux gens qu'on peut y avoir
quelque chose à me data est arrivé de
mauritanie avec ses soeurs salamata
quand je les ai vus pour la première
fois je me suis dit qu'en effet elle
avait des conditions de vie difficiles
mais j'ai surtout constaté qu'elle
n'avait qu'une envie c'était de
reprendre le pouvoir sur leur existence
elle voulait pas qu'on me plaigne elle
voulait prendre part à des projets qu
alors on a lancé toutes les démarches
administratives et puis quand est arrivé
ça me tende attentes
je leur ai proposé d'intégrer la troupe
qui se formaient à l'époque pour
préparer le spectacle de noël
treize hommes et femmes qui se
retrouvaient tous les mardis pour monter
un extrait du bourgeois gentilhomme en
comédie musicale
[Musique]
ils ont répété pendant trois mois à
l'issue de ces trois mois ils ont fait
leur spectacle devant tous les accueils
du centre et devant toute l'équipe et ce
jour là je les ai senti fier
fière d'être considérée non plus comme
des sdf mais comme les membres d'une
troupe à part entière qui avait bossé
pour en arriver là et dont le boulot
suscitait des applaudissements et cette
parenthèse un peu magique pour certains
elle a tout changé
tout d'un coup philippe était plus cet
homme à la rue depuis des années mais au
trompettiste incroyable aminata a
découvert qu'elle avait une voix
puissante et salamata sa soeur un don
pour l' annonce je suis arrivé au centre
avec zéro espoir et très renfermé j'ai
commencé les démarches pour trouver un
hébergement en allemand j'ai trouvé un
spectacle qui se prépare et qui intègre
la troupe j'ai fait du théâtre et de la
danse
en même temps j'ai fait des ateliers de
bien-être et d'autres qui m'ont beaucoup
aidé un mouvement aux gens et à attendre
le temps de prouver les régions on a
fait un sceptre s'est bien passé en
décembre juste après quand tu pars mais
là on a trouvé des agents dans cet
espace dédié aux femmes
il ya un autre atelier dont je suis
particulièrement fier parce qu'en fait
il incarne ce que je veux pour les gens
qu'on accueille celle ateliers bien-être
dans cet atelier en reçoit les femmes
avec beaucoup de second pour les
installant des fauteuils confortables on
leur sert un thé et pendant une heure
elles se détendent
elles font des masques des gommages
elles papotent elle se marre
elles s'échangent des anecdotes et elles
ressortent de la belle est rasséréné
parce qu'en fait on les a reçus comme
des reines
et c'est pas superfétatoire de les
recevoir comme des reines alors qu'elles
sont en grande précarité au contraire
c'est parce qu'elles sont dans une
situation difficile que les égards
d'entonner gratifie son précieux parce
qu'en faisant ça on leur tend un miroir
qui leur renvoie l'image d'une femme
digne d'être considérés et petit à petit
atelier après atelier entretien social
après entretien sociale elles peuvent
reprendre confiance
elles peuvent oser oser laisser parler
leurs envies tenir jusqu'à l'obtention
d'un hébergement trouver le courage de
soigner l'addiction ou de chercher un
travail
alors je vous dis pas de jouer du
molière espère des masques aux
concombres quand on est à la rue ça
sauve des vies pas exagérer en revanche
considéré les gens comme des êtres
humains dignes les leur père réaliser à
quel point ils sont endurants courageux
et bah ça peut les aider à tenir debout
voir leur donner le courage de remonter
les étages de la fameuse pyramide
[Musique]
voilà c'est ce que j'ai appris dans ce
centre ce centre où j'étais venu faire
quelques semaines de bénévolat il ya
sept ans ce centre où j'étais venu
donner --ou en fait j'ai pas mal reçue
j'avais pas vraiment de préjugés sur ce
monde mais je le connaissais pas
aujourd'hui sans tomber dans une
mièvrerie pâteuse j'ai compris que par
voie pour donner confiance à quelqu'un
il suffit de poser sur lui un regard a
priori positif un peu comme celui qu une
équipe de travailleurs sociaux a posé
sur cette bourges qui se piquait de
bénévolat et qui a débarqué un jour de
janvier 2013 pour sauver le monde
[Musique]
e donc ces travailleurs sociaux qui
m'ont patiemment appris métier aux
intervenants passionnés que j'ai côtoyés
et aux accueilli bien sûr qu'il nous
fait confiance
vous m'avez rendu plus riches n'ont pas
de sacs chanel mais d'humanité de de
tolérance d'humilité alors merci
beaucoup merci aminata merci salamata
[Applaudissements]
g
[Musique]
là
tu
une
j'aime
me passer
tu m'as com
[Musique]
tout cas demain
m
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]